I'm a Star Trek fan and I just saw star
trek into darkness now it's time to
review it so in the words of a great man
shall we begin
star trek into darkness so star trek
into darkness is the sequel to the JJ
Abrams Star Trek movie and Benedict
Cumberbatch is blown up in London
cuz he's kind of pissed off and now Jim
Kirk and the crew the enterprise were
like no you messed with the Federation
you mess with us we'll stop more or less
so now we have our movie I was looking
forward to this movie because the
trailers are awesome I'm a big fan of
Benedict Cumberbatch I'm a big fan of
the 2009 Star Trek movie and Star Trek
in general saw that we did there's
there's no reason for me not to look
forward to this movie now I had certain
fears going into this movie that I
addressed in my review the 2009 Star
Trek movie I didn't want to see a rehash
of Kirk and Spock bickering that is in
this movie but it's not a rehash now it
feels like dude I'm your captain you're
my first officer you're supposed to have
my back Spock's like I don't lie though
and sometimes you break the rules and I
have to address that it does feel like
the natural progression of things and I
love that the first 20 minutes or so of
this movie starts out you're like I
don't know if I'm gonna like where
they're going with this so it turns out
being alright you're like okay cool
we're we're on our space adventure and I
did like that in this movie the trailer
makes it look like you have Cumberbatch
and then you have Kirk and crew the
enterprise and they fight and that's
that this movie has cool but it has
layers the trailer oversimplifies the
movie to give you an example and I know
at this point Dark Knight comparisons
are really overused and I get that I
don't want to do it but it's the best
comparison I can give like when you go
into the dark night you're like alright
good guys and bad guys are gonna fly it
and I think I know what to expect and
you see Jim Gordon and Harvey Dent
they're talking about the mob oh my god
the mob still getting its money out we
need to do something about this it has
layers to it it's not just kind of black
and white there are a lot of shades of
grey almost makes it feel real that's
awesome and yeah Benedict Cumberbatch
awesome in this movie the dude is
kick-ass he's smart he's efficient when
he's on screen you're like are there
other people in this scene I don't know
he could be talking to the wall and I
wouldn't give a the dude kills it
he steals all of his scenes heat I
wanted to see what he would bring to
Star Trek and he didn't disappoint me he
was awesome and this movie actually did
have fanservice one of the complaints
about the 2009 Star Trek was that some
fans felt alienated JJ Abrams was like I
want to make a Star Trek movie but I
don't want to necessarily make it a big
fan service movie I want to make a good
movie and he succeeded in that and I
loved it Star Trek into darkness
he still holds to what he wanted to
accomplish in his first Star Trek movie
but there is more fanservice in this
movie I really dug that like you listen
to the fans he was like alright I'll
still do what I want a dupe I will give
you fanservice spoiler alert this chick
is hot her role in the movie doesn't
require much of anything they just
needed a hot chick to be in the movie
and she certainly did it they could have
gotten worse actresses to be the hot
chick in the movie so she was fine we
don't walk away from the movie going oh
yeah that chick you walk away going yeah
Cumberbatch in the end star trek into
darkness was exciting it was cool
Cumberbatch really brings a lot of
really good to the movie I thought
this movie had great character moments
there is a scene in this movie where I
was like I'm turn up and in every
awesome tacular movie there is a moment
in the movie where I mentally go this
movie is really going to have to screw
up at this point to not get an awesome
tacular that was that moment star trek
into darkness is awesome tacular
first awesome tacular of 2013 I believe
all I know is the movies completely
kick-ass Star Trek men fan of the 2009
Star Trek movie movie fan in general who
just wants to watch something cool just
watch it right so star trek into
darkness have you seen it what did you
think about it what do you like more the
2009 Star Trek movie or this Star Trek
movie I personally am like it's like
Batman Begins in the Dark Knight they're
different enough where I can be like I
don't have to choose but personally I
like the original better I just I love
seeing things start whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more